hey what's up you're watching IG likes a
show about things that I like go high
he's doing I hope you're all doing well
and if you're not doing well or you are
doing well no matter how you're feeling
right now I have a video for you that
will give you some great life advice I
watch the entire thing in my attention
span is non-existent warning boys how's
the water and the two young fish swim on
for a bit and that eventually one of
them looks over at the other and goes
what the hell is water it was originally
a commencement speech given by David
Wallace 2005 to Kenyan graduating
college students and now this past week
released on to the internet and this
beautifully shot artistic just fantastic
video I encourage you after you're done
watching this video go and watch this
video whether the fish story is merely
that the most obvious important
realities are often the ones that are
hardest to see and talk about stated as
an English sentence of course this is
just a banal platitude there's no way
that you haven't seen this video you're
the original ramsey he's a neighbor
caught me through again what happened
this afternoon or the song short stories
George Charles Ramsey hears some woman
yelling to you though Charles Ramsey has
his McDonald's right but he goes to the
woman so he gives her a hot meal into
various but it turns out it is Amanda
berry who has been missing for the past
10 years and then of course auto-tune
the news gets their hands on it makes
this fantastic amazing song
there will never be a better song than
Hajj kids hodja hodja kids this past
week adobe is prototyping a
pressure-sensitive stylus slash pen and
if the pens not enough they have a ruler
yeah the digital ruler ruler ruler and
my thing mera the cool thing is these
will work with your tablets and all of
the settings will be stored in the cloud
same settings that you have in adobe
illustrator and photoshop it'll be
inside of your pen like again get access
to things like colors so lately more and
more people have been getting their
Google glass and a lot of these people
who are wearing their Google glass in
public or showing them off they've been
dubbed glass wholes love this picture of
Robert Scoble with his Google glass in
the shower like come on granted there's
a picture of you wear the glasses but
what if you're showering and this could
go many many places I cannot wait to get
mine but you're not going to have a
serious personal conversation with
someone wearing these no matter what
with that being said I cannot wait to be
a glass whole you know I'm a huge fan of
Dennis but I don't like someone's
cutting grass outside shut up these are
some awesome
zebra printed denim by Hudson jeans
along those zebra theme we have some
striped shorts I don't even wear shorts
very often when I try these on they
actually cover up the booty most shorts
now the hates are so short it's like I
don't want my butt crack being shown to
the world
I would like my shorts to hold the butt
in
I also started an idea like Instagram
account which is going to be basically
fashion meets tech and anything else I
happened to like during the week so if
you guys need your daily fix of IJ likes
I'm gonna have a theme every single days
less I forget the updates make sure you
guys like the video if you liked it and
subscribe and be sure to check out the
last video I posted and I'll see you
guys in the next video eyebrows I can't
wait to be a glass